à la fois drôle sensuel fragile ce sont
toutes les facettes de l'actrice et
chanteuse glamour qui sont exposés aux
prises mahé long cours
update marilyn a été imaginé par la
compagnie principe actif
objectif faire revenir marilyn monroe à
notre époque et des clichés pris par
l'un de ses photographes officiels
milton greene ont été réintégrés dans
des photos d'aujourd'hui c'est son fils
joshua green qui a resterait tous les
négatifs de son père avec sa société
archives images et nous a confié ses
photos et ses photos nous les avons
réintégré dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
elles viennent se mêler alors ça c'est
en exclusivité c'est vraiment pour pour
le prisme des photographies de la
collection personnelle de jeu chagrine
piétons qui ont été restaurées qui nous
a fait tirer sur papier japonais et qui
sont imprimés à l étage du théâtre dont
jamais exposé ses photos tous les
recoins du lieu culturel ont été
investis par ces composites au cours du
parcours le public peut également
découvrir le témoignage de l'épousé de
milton greene
l'idée de cette exposition est de
balayer les idées préconçues sur l'icône
des années 50 et de lui rendre hommage
elle était représentée par le hollywood
comme étant extrêmement sexué avec une
image très très glamour et puis c'était
quelqu'un qui avait une vie antérieure
extrêmement riche qui est extrêmement
fine cultiver féministes même
quant à lui en longueur
une installation qui se veut ludique et
interactive avec notamment un jeu sur
smartphone
le public est également mis à
contribution c'est pas juste une expo où
les gens viennent et puis regardant ils
peuvent s'impliquer
donc s'il voit marilyn cela suivante ont
dévoyé marelli mme dans votre cuisine
dans votre librairie n'hésitez pas la
photographier de et à nous envoyer la
photo parce que marilyn viendra
rejoindre l'exposition
cette exposition fait partie d'un
dispositif transmédia le 30 novembre le
public pourra découvrir sur la scène du
prisme sa confession inachevé seul texte
autobiographique de l'icône glamour ou
python